When I first got the first album, it
was, you know, playing the the teardrops
on her guitar. So, it's kind of cool to
see my kids, you know, become fans, too.
It's emotional. Um, and it's exciting.
>> Very excited. We're all
>> big fans.
>> Yes, we're all very big fans. We've been
We love listening to her songs.
Oh, it is so sad to see these young kids
idolizing this woman, Taylor Swift, who
followed the same footsteps as every
other pop star, right? Every other
female pop star had the same journey.
The journey of this downward spiral of
morality, of promiscuity, of the occult.
And Taylor Swift is no different. If you
remember back in the day, Taylor Swift
had this album Teardrops on my guitar.
was so sweet and innocent. She played
country on a acoustic guitar and
everybody fell in love with her back
then and people let their guard down.
They let their children listen to it and
maybe it was safe back then. I'm not
going to judge and say, "Oh, she was
writing some bad stuff back then." This
is how the enemy works. The enemy is
after your children. He's after the
youth because he's trying to corrupt
each generation as they are born into
this world. It's that frog in the kettle
mentality, that metaphor of a frog will
not jump out of a pot if you turn up the
heat slowly and it'll finally boil
itself, right? Well, each generation is
getting more and more debased because of
the mainstream media propaganda that's
this sewage pipe that's being shoved
down each generation that that is here.
So, Taylor Swift, she's followed the
same footsteps as so many other ones.
Look, in the beginning, she used to
proclaim to be a Christian. This is the
back of her album, that first album,
Tear Drops on My Guitar. And look,
here's here she is. She says, "I love
God and I love God for putting you in my
life." Another album that came out. I
guess it was the next album. She said it
right here. I thank God every day for
you. So, there was a time when she
actually claimed to be a Christian,
claimed to believe in God, claimed to
believe in the Bible. here. She's
actually thanking God for an award.
>> I can't even believe that this is real.
And I want to thank God and my family
for moving to Nashville.
>> So, she's thanking God right here. She's
a little older and she's actually
calling herself a Christian. And in this
little caption, it says Taylor Swift on
politicians co-opting faith. She says,
"I'm a Christian. That's not what we
stand for." Listen. Tennessee Christian
values. Those aren't Tennessee Christian
values. I live in Tennessee. I am
Christian. That's not what we stand for.
>> So, this doesn't look like it was that
old. This was 2020 or let's see from the
original on November 25th, 2022. So,
simply 2022. That was 3 years ago. 3
years ago, out of her own mouth, she
said,
>> "I am Christian. That's not what we
stand for." Um, this is the journey that
all these female pop stars take. Check
it out. Miley Cyrus. She used to be a
Christian, but she quit going to church
because gay friends weren't being
accepted. I'm seeing a trend here. I'm
seeing a trend where these pop stars,
they they quit being a Christian because
of the LGBTQ community. either they
themselves are gay or they have gay
friends or whatever and they're giving
up eternal life for sexual debauchery
and perversion. And this is what you
see. Miley Cyrus quit church because gay
friends weren't being accepted. Devado
on CBN News was being baptized in the
Jordan River and had this god-sized hole
in her heart filled. And then shortly
after that, she's coming out saying,
"Oh, I'm pansexual. I'm so fluid now."
The 28-year-old singer describes herself
as pansexual. So pansexual means you're
attracted to anything. It it literally
says here she's attracted to both men
and women and anything in between. So
hey, pull down your pants and surprise
me. Wow. Yeah, this is awesome.
Pansexual based off of the Greek god
Pan, who was all about uh sexual abuse,
child abuse of all kinds. Pansexual,
that's what she identifies as. And then
she came out with this CD called Holy F
and there's a song called Swine where
she's literally just attacking the very
faith that she was, you know, reunited
to a few years prior where she says,
"Picture your faith. Imagine your God
and even your holy Bible is suddenly
banned." Do you understand now? Doesn't
that sound entitled? Doesn't it sound
entitled? It's your book, but it's my
survival. So your book that it makes you
so entitled. I have to like fight to
survive because you believe in this
book. We got to grow them. We got to
raise them. We got to feed them. We got
to bathe them. And if you won't, they
call you a witch to burn at the stake in
Salem. Thought by now we'd change, but
we're still waiting. So this is all
about embracing
child sacrifice. She's saying you you're
you say you're against abortion. You
believe in the Bible, but oh, we got to
raise them. Yeah, there's consequences
to
having sex and it can turn into a child.
And when you have that child, you should
be responsible for your actions and
raise that child and love that child and
yes, raise them and bathe them and feed
them. But no, we don't want to do that.
And because of your holy book, you're so
entitled. Now I have to fight to survive
and raise this thing, this child that I
didn't want. Crazy. AJ Michaela is
thrilled to honor God in Grace
Unplugged. So this girl, her and her
sister are musicians and she was in this
movie called Grace Unplugged where it
was a Christian movie by Pure Flick. And
then later Alli and AJ on how their
music has helped gay fans come out of
the closet. And this is their quote.
It's amazing that our music has helped
fans realize exactly who they are and
what they want in life. So here's
Christians or former Christians who are
so happy that people can come out as
this abomination to live out for the
whole life. I It's so crazy that it's
this LGBTQ lifestyle that people get so
attached to that they're willing to
throw away eternal life, but you
wouldn't do that for anything else.
Like, you know what? My friend's a
murderer and and I'm so happy that he
came out of the serial killer closet and
he can just be who he is, right? And and
my friend who's a a drug addict, just be
yourself. Snort all the cocaine. Go you.
No, it's never like that. Um Katie
Perry, who was Katie Hudson, was also a
Christian.
>> Is there like a theme that you like to
write about?
>> No, I just like to write about um my
relationship with Christ and all the pit
holes that I have encountered. So, she
was writing about Christ as a teenager,
but then we've all heard this interview
clip.
>> I swear I wanted to be like the Amy
Grant of music.
>> Yeah.
>> But it didn't work out. And so, I sold
my soul to the devil.
>> Sold her soul the devil. And then she
came out with a song called I Kissed a
Girl.
And then we see her on stage doing this
literal witch ritual, satanic ritual on
stage. So, what are we seeing here? What
are the common themes that we're seeing
with these female pop stars? They start
out wholesome and Christian and parents
say, "Yeah, you can listen to Katie
Hudson. You can listen to uh Taylor
Swift. Yeah, it's so sweet and
innocent." And then the pop star idol,
the American Idol, think about that
biblically. An idol is raising your
child. And every CD that comes out
pushes the envelope a little more, toes
the edge a little more. It gets a little
bit more edgier and a little bit darker
and a little bit more promiscuous,
and they they throw away their faith.
They embrace the LGBT lifestyle and the
occult. That's what I'm seeing is a a
repeated theme here of embracing the
LGBT lifestyle and the occult.
homosexuality and witchcraft. And I
remember when I made a video talking
about Owl House, Disney's Owl House
cartoon, where the main character is
bisexual. She's uh the writer of it said
her pitch to Disney was girl hangs out
with witch in hell. So, the story is
about a girl living in hell with a witch
and she's by. You see the connection?
Homosexual witchcraft. And when we did
that video, so many people were were
blasting with comments that said, "Be
gay, do witchcraft. Be gay, do
witchcraft." Like, that's a thing. Like
to say that, "Be gay, do witchcraft." I
know why. I see the connection. Go to
any Pride parade and you're going to see
the occult. Go to any pagan fest and
you're going to see the LGBTQ lifestyle.
You're gonna see the holding hands of
the occult and the LGBTQ lifestyle.
Aubrey has a great video called Who is
the Rainman? And also uh the dark
origins of androgyny.
Check those videos out and you're really
going to see that this is nothing new.
This isn't just some alternative
lifestyle. This goes all the way back to
Bale worship. This is literally how they
worshiped Bale, how they worshiped
Satan. Alistister Crowley wrote books on
it called Sex Magic. that this is how
you invoke a demon quicker is to have
sex in ways that were go totally against
God's creation with the same gender in
places it shouldn't be um in in ways it
shouldn't be and this is a sexual
occult practice. It's not just oh
experimenting or or you know being a
little free. That's not what it is at
all. But that's what Satan has convinced
many of the masses. So, here was one of
Taylor Swift's music videos, I think
from her last album before this new one
came out. And look, it says directed by
Drew Kersh and Taylor Swift. So, she
actually directed this
uh video. And what do you see
interesting in this screenshot right
here? Three sixes. I don't think it's
coincidental
because this is a reoccurring thing that
we see in music videos, in movies. Uh we
see these artists literally throw up the
36 hand sign. And here one of these uh
homosexual, transgender, whatever you
want to call these people, drag queens
are wearing a 13 emblem. 13 is an occult
number. You can look into that. But this
particular music video takes place in a
trailer park and every single person in
the trailer park in the music video is
LGBTQ in some form or fashion. Here you
see the snake with butterflies. And I
think this is a fake tattoo. It's too
dark. It's not ashy enough. This is a a
fake press on tattoo. And it was
purposefully put on this person's back
to signal that this is MK Ultra. This is
the serpent that they serve. They're
always having to tell you who they serve
and give their allegiance to Satan.
Here you see a gay couple being married
by a woman priest, Catholic priest.
She's brainwashing the masses with the
LGBTQ. Now, what what's on the other
side is those who are opposing the LGBTQ
here are obviously Christian because the
sign says Adam and Eve, not Adam and
Steve, which is from the Bible. And this
is, you know, they're wearing American
flags and our country and we believe in
God in the Bible. It's Adam and Eve, not
Adam and Steve. And so, they got a, you
know, no sign on a rainbow. It says, uh,
get a brain, morons, and homosexuality
is a sin. And you see it says hell back
there with flames right back here. So
this is And look, this person's holding
their sign upside down. None of the
spelling is correct. You can tell that
she has an agenda to make people who
believe in the Bible, who believe in
God, who believe who are Christians, um,
to be brainless, ignorant morons. And
remember, she is a very political
person. And so right here at the end of
the video, it said, "Let's show our
pride by demanding that on n on a
national level, our laws truly treat all
of our citizens equally. Please sign my
petition for Senate support of the
Equality Act on change.org. She is all
about politics and and getting a message
out there. You know, this isn't just
mindless entertainment. It's it's not
just music. She has an agenda. She
directed that music video that was
propaganda against the Christian
community and pro the LGBTQ community.
And here you see she's at a football
game and she sees the camera. She's
like, "Oh, I got to chug." So, this is
the girl, this is the woman that many
little girls are looking up to and
idolizing where she's like, "Oh, I just
chugged that beer and slammed it while
my friend over here, Ice Spice, is
throwing up horn signs with her hands
and and uh showing her inverted cross
necklace." So, this is who your
daughters are being raised on. If you're
not protecting your daughters and you're
not training them and teaching them what
she is about and you're actually saying,
"Oh, I think it's so cute that my
daughters are growing up on the the the
woman that I used to listen to." Like
the girl in the beginning, the the woman
on the news who said, "Oh, I grew up on
Taylor Swift and now my kids are
obsessed with her, too." This is who's
raising you up. Look at her reaction
when this artist thanks God for her
music award. I want to thank my manager,
James. I want to thank my producer,
Riot, for making the best music.
Shout out all the other nominees in this
category. Um, I want to thank my label
10K and Capital for always supporting
me.
And of course, God. Without God, none of
this would be possible.
this is simply possible.
What do you think about that reaction?
Her reaction was disgust, shaking her
head. No way. I can't believe she's
thanking God. And yet, Taylor Swift
herself was thanking God years ago
before she sold her soul for fame. This
is what all of these celebrities have to
do. If you want to get big like Taylor
Swift, like you can be a one- hit wonder
and not sell your soul. But there is a
line that if you want to be famous like
her, like on every single magazine and
literally the richest female artist,
female musician in the world.
You don't that doesn't just come with
talent. And I'm not trying to knock her
or anything like that. There are a lot
more talented people than her. And the
little bit that I've heard of this new
album, it's really embarrassing.
Honestly, when you look at the lyrics,
it's embarrassing. And so, oh, here's
the clip where she's talking about
political. She's a political person that
puts her ideas in the music. Listen.
>> I want to love glitter and also stand up
for the double standards that exist in
our society. I want to wear pink and
tell you how I feel about politics.
>> So, this isn't just music. She's saying,
"I want to put this in my music. I want
to tell you my political view. I want to
tell you my world view." And that's what
I'm going to put in the music. Not just,
"Oh, it's just fun." On this album, the
same one, uh, she had a track on number
six, ironically, called But Daddy, I
love him. And look what the lyrics say.
It says, "Uh, I just learned these
people only raise you to cage you."
What? Who's these people? Quote unquote,
these people. They only raise you to
cage you. Sarah's and Hannah's in their
Sunday best. So what's she talking
about? Wearing your church clothes,
right? Going to church. So who's raising
them? Christian parents are raising
these girls to cage them. They're in
their Sunday best clutching their
pearls, sighing, what a mess. I just
learned these people try to save you
because they hate you. Her message to
the youth that are listening to her
songs is, "Yeah, your parents that are
making you go to church on Sunday and
making you wear your Sunday best,
they're trying to save you because they
hate you. They only raised you to cage
you. I'll tell you something right now.
I'd rather burn my whole life down than
listen to one more second of all this
griping and moaning. I'll tell you
something about my good name. It's mine
alone to disgrace. I don't cater to all
these vipers dressed in impaths
clothing.
So I think it's interesting she said
vipers because that's exactly what Jesus
called the religious Pharisees. Right?
So here she's using that terminology,
but this is the same song and it says
God save the most judgmental creeps who
say they want what's best for me
sanctimoniously performing siloquiz. I'm
not going to lie. I don't know what that
means. I'll never see thinking I can
change the beat of my heart. So, this is
what she's getting at. This is the
follow your heart message that Disney
puts out in every single movie. She's
doing the same thing. These people
um they want the they they say they want
the best for me and I'm having to like
fake it thinking I can change the beat
of my heart when he touches me and
counteract the chemistry and undo the
destiny. You ain't got to pray for me,
me and my wild boy and all of this wild
joy. If all you want is gray for me,
then it's just white noise and it's just
my choice. So, she's saying, "Look, if
you want me to live a gray, drab life,
I'm going to tune you out like static.
I'm going to do whatever I want to do.
I'm going to have fun with this boy
because it feels like joy." So,
basically, the message is if it feels
good, do it, right? Well, guess what?
Drugs feel good. So, hey, if drugs feel
good, just do it. Hey, immoral sex feels
good. So, hey, if it feels good, do it.
That's what Taylor Swift is teaching
your young daughters.
Then she had these songs that came out
that said that literally had witch
versions of her songs. Taylor Swift,
Willow, Lonely Witch version, Dancing
Witch version,
the Moonlet Witch version. So, she is
putting spells in her music. She is a
witch openly telling you this is my
witch version. And she in the music
video, she's actually wearing a cloak
and she's in the forest. This is where
witchcraft happens in the woods in the
groves and she's doing spells where
she's making these orbs.
She's openly telling you what she's
into. She is wrapped up in rope
symbolizing that she is a slave to
Satan, that she is a puppet for him and
she has to work for him. So now she's a
showgirl. She has to basically
prostitute herself out there so that the
music industry and herself can cash in
on your impressionable children. And I
I'm noticing, remember we saw the the
666 on the dice, right? Well, in this
picture, you just happen to see FF6.
F is the sixth letter of the alphabet.
And I only see three sixes here. FF6. I
don't think that's just some coincidence
because we literally saw it in the other
music video that she directed. And in
this music video, you'll see that
there's this obvious ladder right here.
This ladder represents the spiritual
enlightenment, the spiritual growth of
Freemasonry and and and basically in the
occult in general. The occult symbology
of a ladder is the spiritual
enlightenment, the the spiritual growth.
And what has she done over the years?
She used to be like I, you know, I know
a lot of people really liked her music,
but she used to be like this young girl
playing acoustic guitar in his country.
country is probably one of the least
listened to m genres of music. At least
the least admitted listened to genre and
so but now she's on the cover of every
magazine. How did she get there?
How did she get there?
>> Music. So, thank you so much for giving
me a chance to win a VMA award. I
>> Yo, Taylor,
I I'm really happy for you. I'm going
let you finish. But Beyonce had one of
the best videos of all time.
One of the best videos of all time.
[Applause]
How humiliating, right? Her head is
down. She just won this award. And
Kanye, this was years ago. Actually,
this was about 10 years ago. And when I
saw it happen, I said, "This was a
humiliation ritual." I was like, "She's
about to get huge." And I was expecting
her to be one of the biggest
pop rock stars of all time. And I didn't
see it happen. But now I see it
happening so much that she is actually
the richest female artist on earth.
Check it out. I asked who is the richest
female musician? And the answer says the
richest female music artist is currently
Taylor Swift who has an estimated net
worth of $1.6 billion dollar.
Now that humiliation ritual is what
happens in Freemasonry and in the
occult. It's to make you keep the
secret. The secret that everyone that
all of them all of Hollywood are in the
club. They are doing things that you
would
that they would never want seen public.
They're doing things behind closed doors
that are literally demonic witchcraft
rituals. They are consuming red liquid
from infants to keep their youth. They
are doing spells on their music so that
it goes out and um corrupts all the
people that listen to it. They are doing
these Alistister Crowley sex magic
rituals to invoke spirits because they
have to pay a price to get that type of
fame. And in order to keep the secret,
in order for them to not expose the
secrets that are going on in Hollywood,
they have to have these uh hazing
rituals done to them. There's there's
pictures of all these people doing
things for blackmail.
All this stuff with P. diddy all the
parties and everything. There are
pictures of all these people in video
that if they speak out, such as Michael
Jackson, um who are some of the other
ones? Prince, some of these people uh
that were speaking out, Cat Williams,
there's blackmail on them and next thing
you know, the mainstream media is
saying, "Oh, Michael Jackson, he he
touches little boys and um Prince, I
don't know, they they said that he died
of a drug overdose and he never did
drugs. He doesn't do drugs.
When you speak out, there's a hit on
you. And so, in order to keep that from
happening, they have to use the
blackmail.
Now, I want to show you some some other
things about this new CD that she just
came out with. For one,
uh, Cosmopolitan the magazine said
Taylor Swift's new song Wood is her
runchiest yet. So, what's it say? Direct
quote, "New heights of manhood." What is
it talking about? The song is called
Wood. So, just let your imagination
figure out what it is. Taylor Swift new
song Wood from the Life of a Showgirl.
The name of the album is the Life of a
Showgirl. A showgirl is a a stripper.
So, she's telling you, "This is me. I'm
a prostitute for the industry. I'm a
witch. I am corrupting your children."
And it says right here, "Hello, Prepare
Yourself would dress, I don't know what
song that is, seem completely PG-13.
Taylor Swift's ninth track on on The
Life of a Showgirl starts off as cute
and romantic with lyrics like, "Seems to
be that you and me, we make our own
luck." And it's you and me forever
dancing in the dark and quickly descends
into not safe for work territory. This
is how Satan works. He eases you in. He
gets you nodding your head and tapping
your toe just like um who was that man
from from the Beatles. He said, "I
wanted to lull people into a sense of
security with the with the words
hallelujah." And once they're into the
song and they can't escape, then I slip
in the word Harry Krishna. Harry
Krishna. The same thing. This is how
Satan works. He has to trick you into
the the honeypot into the fly trap. And
it says, so once it's this, you know,
innocent song, then it slips into not
safe for work territory. I mean, Redwood
Tree Ain't Hard to see. His love was the
key that opened my thighs.
These are the lyrics that your daughters
are listening to. those girls in the
first clip I showed that were saying,
"Oh, that girl was like 9 or 10 years
old, saying, "Oh, I love Taylor Swift."
And her mom is taking her to buy this
album. They're waiting in line for it.
And Taylor Swift is such a marketing
genius that she's got multiple album
covers. So, people are going to like buy
all the covers. So, they're literally
buying this CD four times over. They're
going to the movie theater to watch a a
literal movie watch party. And people
are having watch parties for this album.
>> If you heard any random screams last
night around midnight, hopefully you
weren't spooked. It was likely Swift.
>> Did you see I mean these these girls
maybe they're college age, I don't know,
but they are just screaming at the top
of their lungs. And and for what? For
lyrics like he has the key to make my
thighs open. To open my thighs.
And then there's this. Girls, I don't
need to catch the bouquet. M to know a
hard rock is on the way. And baby, I'll
admit I have been a little
superstitious. The curse on me was
broken by your magic wand.
These are all sexual puns that she's
putting in here. Uh, USA Today said,
"The life of a showgirl. Is the life of
a showgirl appropriate for young
Swifties? A parents guide?" I would say
by the title alone, "Showgirl." No. But
some people are not using Discernment.
And so they're saying, you know, parents
may want to press pause before blaring
Taylor Swift's new album around their
young listeners. And it's saying songs
marked explicit mean their their lyrics
include swear words. What I think is
interesting is this CD, this album does
not have a parental advisory on it. It
doesn't have one.
Even though we just read the lyrics, you
heard what was said. It does not have an
uh a parental advisory explicit lyrics
warning on it. So, how many parents are
going to allow their children to wait in
line and buy the CD and listen to it on
their own in their rooms with headphones
on and they're hearing these words over
and over and over. One girl said she
went to see the Taylor Swift watch party
four times in a row on opening night.
And it says right here, eight tracks on
The Life of a Showgirl contain swear
words. Here are which ones they are.
Eight tracks have swear words and
explicit content. It says, "The
following songs from Life of a Showgirl
do not contain swear words." There's
four. Four. All right. Look at the
lyrics on this one. I believe that these
people make a deal with the devil. He
gives them rich and fame and then he
gives them lyrics to say. And it's
Satan's gospel. It's Satan's side of the
story. And listen what he's saying right
here.
I was your father figure. We drank that
brown liquor. First, I want to show you
what what is the brown liquor. Balchce
liquor, a ceremonial alcoholic drink of
prehispanic origin, widely used in in
religious and healing rituals among the
Mayans. Balche, the sacred drink of the
ancient Maya. Each civilization has its
own rituals for connecting with the
sacred and nearly all cultures have or
also have herbal teas, drinks, and food
to help them reach a translike state and
open the spirit for a mystical
encounter. So that's what she's talking
about in this lyric when she's saying
this is Satan talking. I was your I am
your father figure.
You drank that brown liquor.
You made a deal with this devil. Turns
out my what is bigger. This is Taylor
Swift singing the lyrics.
You want to fight? You found it. I got
the place surrounded.
You'll be sleeping with the fishes. What
is What is he talking about? So, if you
try to fight to escape this, if you try
to get out of the deal you made, you
have you found the fight. And Satan's
got the whole place surrounded with
spiritual enemies and physical enemies.
And he's going to make you sleep with
the fishes if you try to expose this
before you know you're drowning. Whose
portraits on the mantle? Who covered up
your scandals? Yeah. See, Satan's like,
"Wait a minute. Who Who was it that
covered up all your scandals?" Right.
You owe me. All that nasty stuff you
were doing, I kept it secret for you.
But now you want to expose me. Oh, you
you wanted to fight. You found it.
You're about to be sleeping with the
fishes like Prince and Michael Jackson.
Mistake my kindness for weakness. I
believe this is Satan talking. He's
like, "Don't mistake my kindness for
weakness. Now I will retaliate
and find your card cancelled. He'll
cancel you if you expose him.
I was your father figure.
You pulled the wrong trigger.
This empire belongs to me. That is
Satan. Because what does the Bible say?
That Satan is the god of this world.
It's his empire. Let's check out that
right now. Again, the devil taketh him,
talking about Jesus, upon into an
exceeding high mountain, and showeth him
all the kingdoms of the world, and the
glory of them, and saith unto him, "All
these things will I give to thee if thou
will fall down and worship me." Matthew
4:8-9.
So Jesus didn't say, "No, you can't give
me all the kingdoms of the world. I own
them."
Satan had the power to offer Jesus all
the kingdoms of the world if he would
simply bow to him. And that offer didn't
stop with Jesus. There are people today
that are taking that offer because they
want to live like gods on this earth and
then they realize that they're in a
trap. They're a prostitute puppet for
the whole world and they can't expose it
or else they'll find a fight that um
will have them surrounded and sleeping
with the fishes.
And here is the verse that says, "In
whom the god of this world," that's
Satan, "the go of this world, hath
blinded the minds of them which believe
not, lest the light of the glory of the
glorious gospel of Christ who is in the
image of God should shine unto them."
Satan is called the god of this world.
And that's what this song is talking
about. It's his empire. This empire
belongs to me.
Leave it with me.
I protect the family. He's saying that
the, you know, you got to disown your
real family, your blood family. She was
raised Christian, so I'm sure that her
parents are not happy with what she's
doing right now, but your new family is
us, the Illuminati, your Hollywood
peeps. We're your family. I'll protect
the family. All of us got a dirty little
secret and I'll keep it protected unless
you speak out.
Leave it with me.
I protect the family. Leave it with me.
I don't think this is a reach. I believe
this is exactly what's going on. And if
you look at some of these other lyrics
that she has, they're just so, like I
said, embarrassing. They're not even
good. I'm not trying to be a hater. Even
though I know these people are Satan's
puppets, I can I can admit if somebody
is actually talented. I don't hear that
talent coming through. And actually,
there's a lot of articles right now of
people saying that they're disappointed
with her lyrical content. Um,
my wife actually brought up a good
point. She said, "See if Max Martin
helped her on this album." Max Martin is
someone who wrote all the biggest hits
for all the pop singers, whether it's
InSync or uh Britney Spears, Mariah
Carey, and yep, Taylor Swift. And so I
looked it up, Taylor Swift. Who wrote
the lyrics for Taylor Swift's Life of a
Showgirl? And look, there it is. Max
Martin. Interesting because he said,
"I'm a human fax machine." That he
that's where he gets these lyrics from.
They just come to him and then he gives
them to the puppets and they go out and
sing it. So you got one man receiving
these messages from Satan himself,
giving them out to all the different
flavors and all the different bait out
there because not everybody likes one
band, right? Somebody might hate in
sync, but they got Taylor Swift. Well,
guess what? The same writer ultimately
Satan is writing the lyrics.
Um, I guess who is Max Martin? Max
Martin is a the stage name of Carl
Martin Sandberg is a Swedish songwriter
and record producer who has influenced
pop music throughout the 21st century.
He's known for collaborating with major
artists like Britney Spears, Katy Perry,
Taylor Swift, The Weekend. I mean, this
dude is writing the music for everyone.
Isn't it interesting? I don't think
that's just a coincidence that there's
one man behind the scenes pushing out
the music. all the lyrical content for
these people who are the biggest stars
on earth right now. What shall it profit
a man if he shall gain the whole world
and lose his own soul? Satan is out here
making that deal. You can have the whole
world and he'll give it to you, but it
comes at a cost. The cost of your soul,
the cost of your reputation. These
people can't even live normal lives.
They can't even go to the grocery store
or go to a restaurant because everyone's
flocking to them. It's like this answer
to a prayer that was really a curse in
disguise. And I just want to leave you
with this.
>> I am Christian
>> and I want to thank God.
>> See the spells that were being cast
right there. Do not trust Taylor Swift
with your children. If you're not
raising your children, Satan will do so
through media, through movies, through
games, through cartoons, through Taylor
Swift. These people cannot be trusted
with your innocent children, your
impressionable children and teens.
Please share this with your family and
friends so they can see that this CD is
not safe for children. I don't care that
it doesn't have a parental advisory on
there. I read to you just the tip of the
iceberg of what's in this. I didn't have
time to read every lyric that she wrote,
but Satan is behind the scenes. He's
working through Max Martin. He's working
through witches like Taylor Swift. And
he is the prince in the power of the
air. And his music is going out like a
spell, blinding the minds of all the
people that are on Earth. If you like
this video, please give it a thumbs up.
It really helps this video get into the
algorithm so more people can see this so
that they can be aware. If you're new to
this channel, please click subscribe and
the notification bell so you don't miss
another video. We come out with videos
all the time. If you want to let us know
something that you want to hear about,
let us know in the comment section.
Please leave a comment. We read every
comment. If you would like to support
this ministry, we are 100%
uh donor-based. We actually do go to
churches and speak though, too. If you
want to invite us to do that, you can
give to us through cantruth.org on Cash
App, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal. We also got a
lot of cool t-shirts if you like those
on our shop. I'm wearing one right now
that is a a they live parody. It says
Candid Truth and he's seeing through all
the propaganda and all the subliminal
messages. If you would like to invite
Candid Truth to come speak at your
church, your event, your school, we do
those all the time. Go to our website,
check out our booking calendar and book
us. We'd love to come meet you in person
and speak to your youth and your church.
And we love you. Thank you so much for
supporting us because we cannot do this
without you. And we will see you next
time on Can of Truth.